now to a large industrial fire in
Indiana that is expected to continue
burning and spewing harmful fumes for
days so that is not good the fire began
on Tuesday it's already burned an
estimated 13 acres at a plastic
recycling facility in the eastern part
of the state Cameron riddle of our
Indianapolis station that's wttv has
been following this in Richmond Forest
Cameron good morning I'm glad to see
you're taking precautions this morning
Gail good morning the air here is the
concern the fire behind us is contained
according to the Richmond fire chief but
the concern now as it continues to burn
is all of the toxic chemicals that are
flowing through the air
this has been a challenging fire just
because it's Plastics plumes of smoke
have consumed the city of Richmond as
the industrial fire enters its Third Day
Public Safety officials say their main
concern is the Hazardous potentially
carcinogenic particles spreading in the
smoke if their breathed then can cause
all kinds of respiratory problems
burning of the eyes tightening of the
chest it could aggravate asthma air
quality concerns have forced
firefighters to battle the Flames from a
distance and led to evacuation orders
for as many as 2 000 people this is no
joke you know chemicals like this and
the burning of the plastic the business
owner is responsible for this mess
responsible for the disaster and
responsible for putting everyone in
danger Richmond's mayor placed blame
squarely on the recycling facility
documents from the city's unsafe
building commission reveal the business
came under scrutiny in 2019 with one
commissioner detailing boxes stacked all
all the way up to the ceiling referring
to some materials as a fire hazard and
pointing to no sprinkler system a Wayne
County Court later supported a cleanup
order for the facility calling the
buildings in question a hazard to Public
Health and dangerous Richmond's fire
chief on Wednesday appeared to suggest
those conditions may have remained as
his team worked to evacuate the scene
and put out the Flames our access was
very hampered by the rubbish in the
piles of plastic that were surrounding
the complex
now in those documents from 2019 the
business owner claimed that the
building's fire suppression system was
actually broken when the previous owner
left CBS News has reached out to that
business owner for common but so far
we've had no luck on a response Tony
Cameron riddle messed up for us in
Indiana Cameron thank you very much do
stay safe